[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE MCDONALD: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
I know it's the last
session of the day.
So hopefully you're not all
trying to run out the door
and get beers or whatever
at the end of the day.
But thank you all
very much again
for coming to Serverless
Security Made Simple.
My name is Mike McDonald.
I'm a product manager on
Google Cloud Platform working
on Cloud Functions, App Engine,
and the newly announced Cloud
Run product.
So just to kind of baseline,
how many people would say
they know what the word security
means, but beyond that nothing?
So like kind of intro
beginner security?
Couple folks.
Maybe like intermediate?
Maybe like you wrote a crypto
algorithm in college once?
And then let's say like
advanced security people?
So like you professionally
write crypto algorithms?
Which you shouldn't do.
Don't do that.
Don't ever roll your own crypto.
So good baseline there.
We're actually
going to start off
just kind of talking very
broad brushstrokes so there's
kind of no assumption
of you know anything
about crazy security things now.
We're going to try and
get on a baseline of,
hey, what are threats?
What are some common threats
that you might deal with?
And then actually say, OK,
what about in Serverless?
Serverless allows you to forget
about a bunch of those threats,
but also kind of
introduces some new ones
that we need to deal with.
And then lastly, running
Serverless on Google
Cloud, again, because
you're running on a managed
environment, we can eliminate
some of those threats
and we give you some tools
to deal with other ones.
And then lastly,
we have our friends
from Protego who are going to
do a demo on how they can also
bring their product on top
of our Serverless solutions
to further increase
your security.
Cool.
So we're going to start
off on a baseline of,
what is a threat environment?
And so we start off with a
very high level view of that,
and it's kind of the category
of who are the people
or systems that may attack you?
And those could be
everything from hackers
for profit on the internet,
foreign governments,
though most likely it's people
inside your organization
who screw things up.
They accidentally
press RMRF.star
and delete everything.
That is still a threat
that you have to deal with.
And then similarly, in addition
to knowing who your threats are
or who the attackers might
be, understanding kind
of what targets are available.
If you have a database publicly
accessible on the internet,
that's an obvious
target, but there
may be some other
less obvious targets.
There have been a lot of
interesting hacking attacks
where someone had
a password written
on a post it note that was
in the back of a photo.
That's potentially a target
that you have to deal with.
And then lastly, what
tools might be used.
If you understand
who is attacking you,
the targets that
they're attacking,
and the tools that
they're using,
you have a much better
way of understanding
how you can defend
against those threats
because that's what
you're trying to do.
You're not trying
to outrun everyone.
You're trying to outrun
the other slow people.
Your security has to be
better than everyone else.
And that's hopefully why
you're coming to Serverless,
because you get a
bunch of that for free
and then you configure
the little bits on top.
So this is also one
of my favorite comics.
Hopefully everyone here
reads a lot of xkcd.
But there's kind of this hacker
world of, oh God, the laptop
is encrypted.
We need to write
a new algorithm.
Do it.
But the reality is it's
a $5 wrench that gets
the password on the laptop.
And so that's kind of this
idea of threat models.
You want to optimize
for what's going
to happen commonly and
defend against that, rather
than those kind of scenarios
that maybe you dream of but are
low probability.
So this talk is actually
kind of modeled off
of a couple of top 10 threats
that we see in Serverless.
So the OWASP Serverless Top 10
and the Cloud Security Group
Serverless Security Top 12.
And those are kind of
the obviously top threats
that they see.
There's a lot of
overlap between these
and we're going to go
through a number of them.
So things like what
malicious code is
and where you might get it
and potential for remote code
execution, denials of service,
storing your credentials
insecurely, and
then everything down
to even this idea of poor
developer experience.
If your developers have
a manual tool chain,
they are copying things around,
there's a much higher chance
that something's going
to go wrong which is
a threat to your environment.
So we're going to start off
with this idea of a zero day.
So how many people have
heard of zero days?
Everyone in the room.
Exactly.
So why does it matter?
Why is a zero day so bad?
Typically you have
this thing called
the window of vulnerability.
So a vulnerability is disclosed.
So like Specter or Meltdown.
We get an email that's
like, oh my god,
this terrible thing happened.
There was a patch out.
You can go and fix
using this patch.
And that's where this kind
of danger zone begins.
Everyone knows that
this is a vulnerability
and it can be exploited.
But ideally you can patch things
quickly enough that that danger
zone is relatively small,
that window of vulnerability
is relatively small.
The problem with
zero days and really
kind of any unknown
vulnerability
is that that danger zone
is now much, much larger.
There is an x point active
somewhere in the wild.
Maybe it's a remote
code execution
in your function or
some insecure credential
that you don't know about.
And until you discover
it, kind of this t
equals 0 all the way up to
the present where it's active,
that's a very, very
dangerous place.
And why this is
important, is those things
could occur anywhere
in your stack.
So if you're building
on top of some VM,
I have a server, a
Raspberry Pi at home running
things on the internet.
I'm responsible for hardware
and network on that.
I have to patch the
operating system when
something like Specter happens.
I'm responsible for that.
I am running a node
server on top of that.
I'm responsible for
updating node whenever
it gets their security patches.
And then I'm also responsible
for the dependencies
that I'm pulling in in my app,
in addition to my app code.
And that's a lot for me to
think about when my Raspberry PI
server is controlling
my light bulb.
And it's relatively low risk
if my light bulb gets hacked,
but it's a lot of stuff
that I have to worry about.
And I would like it obviously
if my light didn't turn on
at random times.
And so the whole
goal of Serverless
is to reduce what
you're thinking about.
Shove all of those
potential vulnerabilities--
the zero days that are going
to wipe out your application--
because you're not worried about
updating the operating system.
You're not worried about
updating the hardware.
You're not even worried about
updating the language runtime,
in many cases.
You're just focusing
on what matters to you
and your business, which is the
application code that you write
and the dependencies
that you're pulling in.
So we do a couple of things
for you in this world, right?
If you're using Cloud Functions,
App Engine, or Cloud Run,
we are automatically doing
a bunch of those upgrades.
So, in the Cloud
Function's case,
things like your function
framework-- so the code
that actually wraps that
little function that you write.
The language runtime
and operating system.
Same on App Engine.
Language runtime and
operating system.
And then on Cloud Run-- so Cloud
Run is our newest serverless
containers product where you can
actually provide an arbitrary
container image, which could
have some crazy operating
system, you could be pulling
in native dependencies.
We don't know, so
we can't do kind
of the same operating system
level things potentially yet.
There is a world where
we're looking at, hey,
we'll give you a
Google Ubuntu base
image that we are
automatically upgrading
or a Google Python base image
that we're automatically
updating.
So stay tuned for more
of that, of how we make
that world a little better.
And then there's
another question,
and it was actually
asked downstairs
in our serverless
panel earlier today.
We are running a
bunch of containers
under the hood for
all of those products,
and we're running them in
a multitenant environment.
That's how we can scale to
10,000 containers in five
seconds.
And we're doing that because we
run on this massive multitenant
infrastructure.
And there's a really cool
product called gVisor.
So gVisor is an
open-source kernel--
you can go to gvisor.dev--
and it basically
intercepts all of the sys
calls from the developer
untrusted container,
and then would remap
them or disallow them
so that you can't have
people going and messing
with other containers.
We also have a thing called
GContain, or GContainer, that
does kind of the same idea,
but for memory and CPUs
so you can't have
noisy neighbors
taking up other resources on
that multitenant environment.
OK.
So that's kind of base
what Google does for you.
Let's talk about another one.
So malicious code and
remote code execution.
So it turns out, there
are lots and lots
of ways to get bad code.
The internet is a
very scary place.
Number one, just don't trust
anything that pulls code
from pastebin, right?
Like, there have been a
number of vulnerabilities.
There was a great one
last year in ESLint
where someone checked
in code they just
pulled from an
arbitrary pastebin URL,
and then evaled that
code and wrote it
to another pastebin URL.
Those are kind of obvious ones,
but there are some other--
having other low
quality dependencies
that may not be as obvious.
Such as, maybe there
are performance bugs
like they do crazy regular
expression parsing that end up
causing performance issues.
Or another really common one is
you have multiple environments,
and so you have a
development environment where
your developers can
do whatever they want,
and then you have a
production environment
that's more locked down.
And maybe if you're
sharing those environments,
dependencies will
make their way over
from development through
testing and into production,
and maybe they don't have the
performance or the security
requirements that you have.
So how do you know about any
of those vulnerabilities,
by the way?
If you're using an
open-source package,
how would you have any
idea if it was vulnerable?
So there are a bunch
of three letter
acronyms that I'm going to
throw out, and, by the way,
feel free-- yes, take
photos so that you don't
have to remember them all.
So CVEs.
I'm sure a lot of people
have heard of these.
So it is kind of
a way of tracking
these common vulnerabilities
and exposures,
and they do so by assigning
every CVE a number.
And so CNAs provide
numbering for those,
so you'd see CVE12345 is x.
And so open-source project--
so Node is a great example
of this--
they have the Node CVE
Numbering Authority.
So every single Node
issue gets a number,
goes into their tracking
system, and then
you can look it up using these.
So these are kind of the
open-source databases
for taking a look at,
hey, what vulnerabilities
may be out there.
There are also a
bunch of other tools
if you're more in this space
that have kind of scraped this
and provided it a better world.
So things like
Greenkeeper or Sneak
are great ways of just, hey, I
want to actually kind of make
sense of this, and
even potentially check
my dependencies locally.
And then I think
we'll have a demo
later of doing this as well.
Cool.
So denials of service,
another attack that I think
a lot of people have heard of.
So a classic denial of service
that everyone thinks about
is you have some fixed
number of resources,
you have external
traffic coming in,
and now maybe you have
malicious traffic.
And so that traffic
starts coming in
and it overwhelms the
resources, and your machines
start backing up and failing.
So serverless
actually introduces
another several relatively
interesting denial-of-service
attacks.
You can have the traditional
resource exhaustion
where hey, your function or your
app only has two gigs of RAM
and you'll run out of RAM, or
you only have so much network
throughput.
But because we're
focusing more on code,
you could have some other really
interesting ones of code errors
that maybe it was
a correct request,
but due to some
regular expression bug,
now you end up with
resource exhaustion.
And then my personal
favorite, which
is very new for serverless.
Server infrastructure
scales infinitely, right?
Hopefully you saw that demo
of 0 to 10,000 instances.
I've profiled it, and that's
know a million requests
a second.
The thing that
will run out first
is your credit card, right?
You're going to hit
that and you don't
want a $10,000 bill
or $100,000 bill,
and things will start breaking.
And so that's this
financial denial of service
that serverless is so great--
it's so great on one
side, and results
in this interesting
problem on the other.
So really common one here,
again, with functions, we
will start scaling
up and maybe there's
this impedance mismatch.
So for those of you who
have used SQL databases,
you can run out of file
descriptors, right?
You have so many machines
on the front end trying
to connect to this and you'll
exhaust your resources.
So we provide a
really nice tool that
allows you to set a maximum
number of those functions that
are running.
So functions are
single concurrency,
they're handling one request.
So you can actually say,
I want four instances
because I know that I have a
backend resource that can only
handle four concurrent
connections,
or whatever the number is.
And we can set that upper bound.
And what will happen
now is we will
start getting
external traffic, we
will start spinning
up resources,
and then, above
that, we'll start
kind of load-shedding that
and applying back pressure.
And so we'll start queuing
up all those requests,
we're not going to drop them.
But we will just
start processing them
so you only get four at a time.
So it's a nice way
of, again, when
you have this impedance
mismatch of serverless
can scale infinitely, but
maybe the backend resources
that you're using can't,
you can use max instances
to try and solve that.
It's worth noting that apps and
containers running on Cloud Run
are multi-concurrent
by default. So I
mentioned functions
are single concurrency,
so they're doing one
request per instance.
Apps will actually do multiple
requests per instance.
So if you're running
App Engine or Cloud Run,
we will actually start
sending those requests back
to your application.
So for Cloud Run,
for instance, we
say you get concurrency
limit of 80 by default.
So every instance,
assuming it doesn't run out
of memory or CPU,
it's kind of bound
to 80 concurrent requests.
And obviously, you can
put that higher or lower
depending on what you need.
But just something to
know, if you really want,
you could set your Cloud Run
app to single concurrency
and go back to that model.
But we give you
that flexibility.
OK.
Insecure credential storage.
Don't store passwords
in plain text.
I feel like I don't
need to say that,
but it still happens,
especially when people
write really small things.
There are a lot of
places where you're
going to encounter credentials
and you may need to store them.
So storing database username
and password, right?
I see it all the time.
Maybe you're doing
OAuth credentials,
so you're signing a user in and
you're storing access tokens.
You're doing some
kind of crypto.
Maybe you have symmetric
keys, or you're
storing asymmetric keys.
Or, similarly, maybe you
have publication credentials.
So publishing your code
to GitHub or deploying it.
We'll talk about the most
common one that I see.
So storing secrets
in code, right?
You end up with, we're
connecting in our function
to a mySQL database
and someone says, hey,
here are the user
name and password.
And your function code
can leak, maybe you
accidentally make your
GitHub repo public
and everything is bad.
Someone can just connect to this
database and take your data.
So maybe you want to do
something like storing secrets
in environment variables.
That kind of solves
one of the problems of,
hey, let's just set
the database user
to root and store it there.
And your code
looks a lot better.
It just says, hey
process.env.DB_USER,
DB_PASSWORD.
Now, if this gets
public on the internet,
it's fine because you're
binding those credentials
in when you actually deploy
in the environment variable.
But there are actually a bunch
of other potential issues
in that world.
We'll actually, I
think, see an attack
on that at the end in a demo.
And so you may want to
consider things like Cloud KMS.
So Cloud KMS will
let you do encryption
of, say, a file
in GCS, and so you
can store all of your
secrets in that file
and then pull them out.
Or similarly, if you want to
use a tool like HashiCorp Vault,
maybe you're already
running an instance of that
within your own company.
We also have a link there if
you want to run Vault on GCP.
And those are more secure
ways of storing secrets.
There's a really
great blog post by one
of our developer advocates,
Seth, on how to do those.
So I think he writes a
bunch of go functions
and a bunch of
Python functions that
show how to do a number
of different secrets
in serverless type of scenarios.
Cool.
So those are all--
some of them are unique to
serverless, but most of them
are just general
application security things.
Execution flow
manipulation, I think,
is much more unique to
serverless, and here's why.
So we can imagine that I'm
building a simple function that
deploys--
that writes some content
to a cloud SQL instance.
But the reality is
these are microservices,
so I'm going to actually
break them apart
into the smallest unit of
whatever they are doing.
So that's one line of code.
So maybe I want to
save some content,
maybe I have a markdown file
and I'm writing it to HT--
and transforming to
HTML and then saving
the HTML into a database.
So I'll have one
function that's, hey, I
want to process some content.
And that does markdown to
HTML and then one thing
that actually saves the HTML.
So you can imagine
the happy path here
was just straight through.
My one function calls
my second function,
my second function
calls the database.
But in this case,
these functions
are public on the internet,
people can just kind of
call around them, and you may
get a malicious call that's
like, hey, I just want to save
some arbitrary data that's
maybe not HTML, or
maybe not markdown,
or anything that kind
of doesn't respect
the flow of the application.
That's a problem.
So we've introduced it,
actually, in Cloud Run.
You can already go
and use it today.
And in Cloud Functions,
it's an alpha.
We're still working
on rolling that out.
It's kind of hard to add to a
generally available product.
But what it does
is it allows you
to specify cloud IAM
policies on your functions
and your services.
And so that would allow you to
authenticate developers or end
users or the other
services, be they
Cloud Functions or Cloud Run
services, or on-prem things
that you're authenticating
with a service account.
And the other big change
here is that services
will become private by
default. So in Cloud Run,
when you deploy your Cloud Run
instance, it's already private,
and you have to make it
public manually by adding
a policy down there.
So that --allow-authenticated
sets all users
can invoke this service.
Similarly with functions.
So what does it look like?
We can have our first
function, that process-content
function, say, I want to
allow anyone to invoke me.
So we're going to say, all users
get the cloudfunctions.invoker
role.
And on our second
function, we're
actually going to say, OK,
only this first function can
invoke me.
So that provides a little
bit of security where someone
can't come around, all right?
So we've now
secured that channel
between our two functions.
So when someone tries to come
in and save data directly,
IAM is like, nope, we don't
allow that, you can't do it.
But, for your
developers, they can just
say, hey, I want to curl
this using an identity
token that I'm
pulling from G Cloud
or that I've generated via some
other tool, and they can go
and actually test
that out if they want.
And what about other
cloud services?
So maybe it's not a human
user that it's calling
your process-content functions.
Maybe you have a scheduled
job, or you have task queues,
or you have data
coming from Pub/Sub.
So each of those products, Cloud
Scheduler, Tasks, and Pub/Sub,
can get a service
account with a role.
So that could be Cloud
Function Invoker, or similarly.
And they can then make
authenticated requests out
to GCF or Cloud Run or other
services on the internet.
And it's both secured
in transit via SSL,
but then also, it
gives that identity
token that can be
validated by the IAM stuff
that we just talked about.
So it takes that token along,
they validate it, awesome.
And, as I mentioned, also
available in Pub/Sub,
you can do authenticated push
subscriptions out of Pub/Sub.
So it's really,
really nice for kind
of creating this very
secure environment.
OK.
And then I actually saw
a question on the Dory,
so hopefully whoever
asked this is here.
There is a question about
network restrictions.
So currently, only App Engine,
of those three products,
offers firewalls.
So actually, Cloud Functions and
Cloud Run don't yet offer them.
They are not yet integrated
with Cloud Armor,
but that is something
that we're looking into.
In Google App Engine,
you can say, hey,
I do want to create
a firewall, and that
would be if you know that there
is some known malicious actor,
you can blacklist that IP.
Or maybe you are operating
within an environment
where you need to
whitelist certain ones.
Otherwise, strongly recommend
identity-based security.
A lot of large companies
that I've talked to,
do this strong outer wall
and then no security inside.
And that's obviously not
good because if someone
does penetrate that outer wall,
they can do whatever they want.
And identity-based security,
kind of going back to those
granularity--
to a granularity thing,
sort of makes the barrier
feel a little more permeable.
But generally, every service
has their own little wall
around it, which makes
that more secure.
It's all trade-offs
in engineering.
OK.
So continuing on, the
ways of authenticating
your application.
We see, a lot of times,
that people end up
with overprivileged
identities in those functions.
So by default, every
function shares
the same identity and that
identity has the editor role.
So it can actually
go and spin up VMs
and do a bunch of things.
And that's basically
because we said, hey,
we know that people want to
build functions to demo things
really quickly, they
should be able to do that
without having to learn all
the complexities of IAM.
But we then said,
OK, well, obviously,
if you're deploying these
things in production,
you need this concept
of least privilege,
where your function
can only access the one
thing that it needs.
And so that is
where this concept
of per-function identity
comes in and says,
OK, we know that this function
needs exactly this role,
we don't want it
shared with anyone.
And that's how we actually
talked a little bit
earlier about how our save--
or our processContent
function can
talk to our saveData
function, and only those.
So we can walk through
an example of that.
I can create a service
account called processContent,
and I can say, OK, on Cloud
Functions, I'm going to grant--
on that saveData function,
I'm going to say, OK,
serviceAccount.processContent@
whatever gets the Cloud
Functions invoker role.
And then I can
deploy my function
using that service account.
So what I've done is I've
said, OK, on functionA,
you get this specific role, I'm
going to deploy you with that.
And on functionB, that
function can invoke it.
And then we can do the
same thing, actually,
for our second function.
So our second function
is talking to a Cloud SQL
instance.
So we can say, OK, we'll give
you the saveData function,
or we'll give you a service
account called saveData
and we'll do the
same thing, right?
We'll say, hey, on the project,
give you the Cloud SQL client
role so you can actually create
a connection to Cloud SQL.
And then we will deploy
our function using that.
So now, with
per-function identity,
functionA can talk to
functionB, and functionB
can talk to our database.
And really, the
important thing here
is functionB can't go and talk
to any other thing, right?
It can't go out and talk to
GCS or any of the other cloud
services because it
doesn't have that access.
And what about things
within network restrictions?
So maybe you're not running
a Cloud SQL instance.
Maybe you're running
some other database
that doesn't integrate
well with Cloud IAM,
but it's within a VPC.
So you're running that on cloud
and we obviously can't just
make an HTTP
request to your VPC,
you can use a VPC connector.
So these are now
in beta and they
allow you to talk to instances
obviously within a VPC.
So GCE or GKE, things like
Cloud Memorystore that
are also running within a VPC.
And then even on-prem, you
can go through compute running
in that VPC on to on-prem.
So again, you configure
at deploy time,
you say gCloud functions
deploy with a VPC connector.
And that will let you go through
that connector to that compute.
OK.
I'll let photos
continue, and then can
we switch over to the
demo machine, please?
OK.
It wants me to relaunch Chrome.
Yes.
So what we're
looking at is the--
well, you're looking
at all of my functions.
I have a lot of them.
And we have a really, really
simple view of the app
that we just created.
So we have functionA
and functionB.
And what functionA does
is, functionA literally
just proxies to functionB.
We can actually look at
the source over here.
And we can say, hey, it's
going to fetch a token
and then call our other
function with that token.
And then functionB literally
just returns 200 OK.
There's-- It's not
even worth looking at.
It's a really, really
small function.
But as you just saw, currently,
anyone on the internet
can talk to either of
those functions, right?
But we really want it such
that functionB can only
be accessed by functionA.
So over in the
service accounts page,
I created functionA a thing
called No Role where I just
say, hey, this is a
service account that I
want to give no permissions to.
And what we can do to secure our
app is we can edit functionA.
So currently, it has the
default compute service counts.
We could say, hey,
we want to give you,
functionA, a service account.
We will redeploy you and
then we can, on functionB,
open up that permissions tab.
And you'll notice, the
invoker permission,
which allows anyone to access
it, it has all users currently.
It's a public function.
So we'll delete that.
And just to prove to
you that's deleted.
So, come on.
Takes a second to propagate.
Should be that B. Live
demos are always fun.
We'll just create a
new one. functionB.
OK.
I think I have given it.
One second.
FunctionB.
We will add, to functionB, the
service account from functionA.
And then I will debug
it a little more.
So we can just paste that in and
say, yep, the functionA service
account.
We will give you the Cloud
Functions invoker role
and save that.
Then, as you can see, there
are a lot of who else has--
oh.
I'm assuming that that role
has been given another--
that that user's been given
another role, but let's
just quickly try it again.
OK.
Oh, well, I must've
flipped something.
Let's take a look
over here again.
So over here, I have
given functionA all users.
And then functionB, I will
just actually redeploy it
with its no-role service account
instead of the App Engine
default one, and
see what it does.
I'll just give that a second.
But the end result
should be not this.
Or we should get OK through
there, and we should-- there.
So this has been
redeployed, and that is not
public on the internet.
And then this one.
That is OK.
So there we go.
Took a little while,
but we're there.
And so what we've
done, again, functionA
is running with its
particular service account.
We can go and check that out.
So it even says, hey, it's
running under the functionA
service account.
functionB will be running under
that no-role service account.
And I'll just pull
them out and we'll
refresh them manually to prove.
There we go.
OK.
Back to the slides, please.
So there are a couple
of other issues
that we may face along the way.
So we talked about this
concept of least privilege
within GCP of your
function only being
able to talk to a Cloud
SQL instance and not a GCS
instance, for instance.
So there are a
couple of other ways
that data may be
exfiltrated from your app.
For instance, that
processContent
function, instead of sending--
making that HTTP
request to saveData.
Maybe it's going to say, oh,
send it to evil.com and steal
all of that data.
And that could be caused by
something like a remote code
execution, or maybe you have--
that the name of that URL
is in a variable and someone
somehow got in there
and changed it.
And another similar
one is, maybe
the path is the same where
you're still storing data
correctly, but now someone
has dumped your environment
and is saving that
to the database.
And now your data
is stored somewhere
where it shouldn't and maybe you
have another thing that says--
you have another function
that's readContent,
and now they can read the
content of your database
username and password.
There are a number of
very interesting threats
along that model.
And a similar one that
actually could cause those
is things like query injection.
So hopefully everyone has
heard of you know SQL injection
attacks.
Another xkcd comic about
little Bobby Tables.
Don't name your kid a valid
SQL statement because things
will not end well.
I highly recommend just reading
all of xkcd, by the way.
It's great stuff.
And so maybe we have
our saveData function,
and it does something like this.
It's like, hey, I'm going
to create this query string
and just save my data
directly into the database
and pull it in
directly from the body.
Well, that's great until you
name the user Mike DROP TABLES
Posts.
And then we're inserting that
directly into our database.
Wouldn't it be great if, hey,
we could write a bunch of code
to manually escape that.
We could even do that galaxy
brain thing of a lot of SQL--
Libraries will actually
provide a really nice way
of doing those queries for you
that automatically escape them.
But there are actually a number
of third party providers,
some of whom we have here
in the room today, who
can make this a little easier.
So folks like Intrinsic,
Protego, and PureSec
offer a number of
categories of defenses
for your serverless
applications.
So some of them
occur at build time,
so preventing the shipping
your functions with editor role
because they can say, hey,
based on data we've seen,
you should only need
these three privileges.
And then they can also do things
like check all of those TVE
databases to make sure that your
dependencies aren't vulnerable.
And then they also provide a
category of runtime defenses.
So doing the kind of web
application firewall type
things to prevent SQL
injection, or restricting
read from the file system
so someone can't just
dump your entire process or
read all of the local files,
or doing things like
controlling outbound networking.
So don't send data to evil.com.
So I'll highlight
one of the tools,
and then we can have
Protego come up on stage
and demonstrate theirs.
So one of them is called
FunctionShield, so by PureSec.
And it does a couple of things.
So you can just say disable
outbound networking or disable
read and write from
slash temp and you
can do a couple of things.
You can say, hey, I want to
actively block all of these,
or you can say hey, I only
want to alert on them.
So it shows up in
Stackdriver Logging,
it says, hey, it looks like
this request was attempted,
we would have failed that if you
were in strict mode, otherwise
we're just letting you know.
So this is more about
the letting you know
and then potentially
locking things down.
So for instance, I run my
functions, most of them
don't need to create
child processes.
And so I say, yep, alert
me on outbound HTTP,
but disallow read and write from
temp, disallow child processes,
don't allow anyone
to read the source
code, that kind of thing.
And then Hillel, do
you wanna come up?
He can give a demo
on Protego and what
they provide in this space.
I'll hand you that.
I don't know if
you need it, but--
HILLEL SOLOW: I need it.
I was sure I'd
fall in the steps.
That was my big vision.
Cool.
Thanks, Mike.
So before I hit play--
I guess I'll figure that out.
Before I hit play, just a
quick word about what we do.
I think Mike set it
up in terms of what
we look at in terms of
security, both at build time
and at runtime.
For security, one of
our particular focuses
is on using automated tools to
understand what the code does
in order to automate all the
configuration of the things
that Mike just talked about.
So try to make it so that
you don't have to sit there
and configure what you
think your function should
do or shouldn't do,
but rather developers
write code and security can be
assured that the code can do
the things it can do,
and then the security
policy is going to prevent
the things that it can't do.
That's a big focus for us.
Whether it's IAM roles, runtime
policy, permissions, defense,
et cetera, all that is automated
in a way that's driven by code.
So let's see a quick demo.
So this is-- we announced
availability of our product
for AWS, those guys,
back in September.
We've been hard working at
getting the things that we
do to do work well
on GCP and take
advantage of some of
the cool things that
are in this platform.
And I think we expect--
don't record me, but, by
the end of the quarter
it's about two
months to be able--
let's say public beta,
if not availability.
But I wanted to give
you a quick glimpse
of what the product
does and how it works.
So I'm going to hit play.
I may hit pause a
little bit, just
if I see it's running too fast.
I did two things.
OK, first off all, I
was going to apologize
for recording my
demo, but now I feel
better because live demos
are always bad and--
MIKE MCDONALD: Demos are hard.
HILLEL SOLOW: --and
I feel like you--
what am I doing here?
Will that play?
OK, so here's the quick setup.
If I hit space, will it pause?
MIKE MCDONALD: Yes.
HILLEL SOLOW: It will.
Cool.
Here's the quick setup.
We've got a single-function
app running in Google Cloud.
It's a Slack chatbot.
So we're going to interact
with it through Slack.
We're going to send messages
to it through Slack,
we're going to
get messages back.
We'll do a quick tour of what's
in the app and what's there
and what we're doing,
and then we'll just
show you how the app works.
And then we'll start attacking
it with different attacks,
and kind of see how the
platform reacts to it.
So you can see we've
got a function,
you can see all the runtime
information, et cetera.
You can see we've
got a bucket, right?
Can I-- I can't even see
what's going on here.
Yeah.
MIKE MCDONALD: Cloud SQL is--
HILLEL SOLOW: There's
a bucket in there.
Cloud SQL is in the bucket.
It's good that you can see.
OK, now you can see our
platform, or what we see.
So this is the
Protego dashboard.
You can see the view of
the application, what
resource it triggers,
what we know about it.
We'll dig into this
particular function.
You can see there
are two functions.
We're going to go
into one of them
and show you the posture
of that function.
So what is everything that
we know about the function,
how is it triggered, what can
it do, what's its runtime,
all that information.
And particularly we're
going to focus on
what's it allowed to do versus
what we think it's supposed
to be allowed to do, because
we've analyzed and understood
the code.
And so we know which
permissions it needs
and which it doesn't need.
We also know what
things it needs
to be able to do at runtime.
What processes it needs
to be able to launch,
we know what network
connections it needs to make,
and so those things
have been whitelisted.
Anything else, we
can then block.
And we'll see that in a second.
If we take a look at
the task view here,
this is the part of our product
which is kind of more the run--
the build time tool.
But you can see it
here in the product.
It's telling us, hey, we've
got a permissive role.
Look at all these
permissions that came
by choosing a managed role.
And actually, these are
the only permissions
this function needs
to run, and if you
want to aim for least
privileges in an automated path
where you can build service
accounts for each function that
have just the permissions
that they need,
rather than all the
permissions that
come with wildcarding or
choosing sort of managed roles,
et cetera.
We also see a
vulnerable dependency.
So Mike talked
about that earlier.
We're detecting the
CVE for that dependency
and giving information about it.
So let's interact a little
bit with this chatbot.
We're going to just
send some messages to it
and see how it reacts.
So you see that when we
write-- this is about as
sophisticated as it is.
We type a message and it types
something random and hopefully
sometimes funny back.
It also stores a
history of our messages,
we can upload files to it.
So we just wanted to
make sure we had a setup
and we can do all these
different injection
attacks on it.
So here, we'll upload a file,
and it'll store it, et cetera.
You can see that we
put the file in there.
We'll pop over to
the storage bucket
and see that that file got
uploaded to that storage
bucket.
All right?
Let's take a look.
There we go.
So there's our file
we just uploaded.
So now, if we go back
and we start seeing what
malicious things can we do.
Let's try doing a little bit of
SQL injection on this, right?
So we're seeing that when
we ask for latest messages,
we're getting back a
list of latest messages
from the database.
That makes us think there's
some SQL inside the database.
We're going to send the
message, which has got some SQL
injection in it.
So remember, the functions
would take these messages
and insert them into the
database using an insert query.
But now that we shoved it
a little select text there
as well, we're going
to magically get
some data stuffed
into the database that
shouldn't have been there, and
now we can pull it back out.
So that was what Mike
described before,
where we leveraged the
ability to do some injection.
To put something into a database
that shouldn't have been there,
and then we pulled it out.
Now we'll do another
injection attack.
We'll do some code
injection here.
This code injection is
going to essentially just do
curl inside the function.
So we're taking advantage
of that node-serialized bug
that you saw earlier.
In the posture
view, where you saw
we were using a
vulnerable library,
let's take advantage of that.
And you can see how, when we
execute that, send that message
to the Slack chatbot,
it's generating a Chrome
request back to our server.
So we now know,
hey, this thing is
vulnerable to code injection.
Cool.
Let's see what other data
we can extract out of it
or let's see what we can do.
In this case, let's
delete the file
that we created earlier,
which is something
we shouldn't be able to do.
And what's it-- I
want to point out
about that is, if
you saw earlier,
this function shouldn't
be able to delete things.
It doesn't need that permission,
but we gave it that permission
and now the attacker can
exploit that permission
to take advantage of that and
delete a file that he shouldn't
be able to delete.
So had we configured the
IAM permissions correctly
for that function, we wouldn't
have been able to do that.
Now here you can
see what Protego
sees when these things happen.
So inline, this stuff
is being-- in this case,
we're in alert mode.
I didn't mention that.
We're in alert mode, so we're
not blocking anything yet,
but you can see all
the types of events
that Protego is picking up.
I see command
injection patterns,
I see behaviors I didn't expect.
All these things are being
detected and could be blocked
and you could get
all that information.
And then we can go and
switch that into block mode.
So we switch our defense
mode on to block mode.
We can then try the same
attack again, and what we'd see
is that attack
wouldn't happen at all.
So let's go back to
Slack and we'll just
try that same
injection attack again.
And hopefully nothing
will happen in the bottom.
I say hopefully.
It's a video, right?
You guys know how it ends.
Here you go.
So nothing happens
in the bottom.
So we try that same
injection attack.
The same mechanism
that we talked--
that I showed you
before detected it,
but now we're
blocking it inline.
And just to give a little
illustration of that,
we can pop into the
logs for that function,
and we can see what Protego
is logging into the logs
of that function in
real time as it happens.
And here you can see, if
you look really carefully,
what the event was,
what the pattern was,
or event was that were blocking.
And in this case, you
see the type of reaction
was block, as opposed to what
would've been there before,
which is alert.
So we're actually detecting
and blocking in real time,
as well as reporting it.
So that's us.
Cool.
MIKE MCDONALD:
Thank you very much.
HILLEL SOLOW: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE MCDONALD: So the last thing
that I wanted to talk about
was a poor developer experience.
So one of the
goals of serverless
is to abstract away
a lot of the toil
and give developers a really,
really fast way of developing.
But there are still developer
experience speedblocks
or roadblocks along the way.
So a number of issues that we
see, particularly people using
shared environments.
That's a really common way to
pollute your database or leak
credentials or similar
things because you're
sharing that information
that really shouldn't
be shared across environments.
So using project boundaries
to enforce that isolation
is a good developer
experience practice.
And using tools like
Deployment Manager or Terraform
to then deploy your functions.
It's really easy to just do
gCloud, functions deploy,
but especially for
your production
and similar environments,
you want to actually
have a bunch of that automated.
Which is going over
to our second side.
If you have a slow toolchain,
or you're manually SCP'ing files
from one place to another,
you're going to end up with
security issues just because
people make mistakes.
So setting up CI/CD tools, so
Spinnaker or Cloud Build, to,
hey, I actually
have a couple apps
that are running in the
Cloud Source editor.
So I edit all of my code there.
I then commit it to get repo.
It's picked up automatically
by Cloud Build.
Build's entirely
deployed the containers,
does a traffic split, and
everything is kind of safe
and I don't have
to worry about it.
So I'm not manually
doing those things,
and I'm not going to screw
it up because I did it once
and I tested it.
So we actually already
demoed, so I'm going
to just leave that slide there.
But we have a
couple minutes left.
If folks have questions,
please walk up to a microphone.
I don't think we can
deliver them, unfortunately,
but I'm happy to
answer questions.
Otherwise, thank you all
very much for coming.
I really enjoyed it.
Hopefully you learned a lot.